[Music]
Gordon Ramsay has never been in the
business of redemption
Horta okay okay he has but now he's cut
me in my name is Monte Carlo you send
Gordon pictures of your horrible dishes
he makes fun of them and then I get to
make them over today we are making over
I don't know what that is that a
meatloaf that looks like the driest
meatloaf it has no color and it's glazed
with like it looks like the sludge you
find at the bottom of a dumpster ooh
Brooklyn what is going on my friend oh
yeah
let's redeem this meatloaf first things
first we got to build a ton of flavor
and the way that we do that is a
scorching hot pan and the foundations of
flavor I'm talking about onions the heat
is going to take all of the water out of
the onions are gonna start to turn
yellow they're gonna release a bouquet
and once that happens we're going to add
a little celery and then some carrots
and that my friends is mirepoix a little
garlic salt and we have foundations for
a flippin meatloaf miracle the only
orange in this dish are these incredible
carrots
you're welcome Brooklyn we're gonna
we're gonna do you right no worries
honey now we are going to add some
mushrooms these are gonna soak up all
the incredible juices those carrots and
that celery and those onions have
released we also need to add spice so
a little cayenne pepper a little paprika
some cumin and coriander pan it's going
to taste even better in your mouth okay
look at the color do you see that colors
where it's at now we're gonna add some
sauces I called these mommy bombs fish
sauce soy sauce chicken stock
red wine oh I love that song and
buttermilk okay we're gonna reduce that
liquid by half but I don't want all the
liquid gone we need that liquid it's
gonna help us with our very last element
our bread crumbs you see these are panko
bread crumbs you don't want to put these
all dry and your meatloaf which I'm sure
you did because they soaked up all of
the juices and then your meatloaf looks
like cardboard Brooklyn come on you can
do better
all right we're gonna take this off the
heat now a little more salt and we're
gonna get it in the mix
fit your stand mixer with your paddle
attachment you can do this by hand but
why the first thing you're gonna do is
take two different types of meat you're
gonna have 1 pound of ground beef
I don't want lean beef lean means dry
you want fat so go for an 80/20 minimum
and then we're going to add pork did I
mention I was Puerto Rican now it's all
about being gentle you don't want to
overmix if the over Meg ends up dense
that's it
ten seconds now salt Parmesan cheese
eggs eggs will help bind your mix
together boom boom
now we're gonna mix this up
not a lot don't go crazy let's do a
little more salt why not it's a lot of
meat in there it's two pounds of meat
once you see that the eggs are
incorporated you're gonna want to shut
it down and you are going to add all of
this incredible veggie mix flavor baby
flavor flavor flavor that's what it's
all about
this is gonna add texture it's gonna add
earthiness it's gonna add a little
crunch keep it moist all the things whoo
I can already tell this one's a million
times better than your dish I'm sorry
Brooklyn but when you know better you do
better oh oh yes okay now it shouldn't
meet mommy so get your pan cook it up
taste it means a little more salt
okay you see you think it's a lot of
salt but really it's not enough one more
mix all right we are ready to go let's
shake this baby slanted let me show you
a trick you want to make sure that there
are no air bubbles in this loaf why cuz
air bubbles make your low crack and we
all know crack is wack now we shape the
low but before we put it in the oven
we're gonna do a little of this
sorry sound guy I'm sorry dude
now you're gonna dock your meatloaf
might have done this with your pie dough
before it just creates little holes for
steam to escape which eliminates the
possibility of your loaf cracking take a
piece of aluminum foil about the size of
a sheet pan and cover this really well
then take a deep pan because this is
gonna release a lot of juices you don't
want them falling out look at this
action ready
Oh inverted what we're doing right now
is we're going to cook this in our oven
at 350 degrees for about 30 to 40
minutes or until the center reaches 140
and that my friends is going to give us
beautifully shaped laufen it's been 30
minutes let's check on the slope
gracious look at all of those juices
that's not gonna be a dry meatloaf
Brooklyn now very carefully you're gonna
lift the corner of this very hot tin
don't burn yourself that's looking
pretty amazing we're gonna continue
cooking this baby until it reaches a
hundred and forty degrees we've raised
the temperature to boil to give it color
quickly and now we're gonna make an easy
glaze take some ketchup a little tomato
paste we're just your sauce a little
Tabasco for heat mmm honey yeah you're
gonna add a little sweetness there okay
and we're just gonna incorporate all of
those liquids with a touch of salt a
couple of big cracks of pepper and that
is our ketchup place oh yeah smells like
right down
okay that's done man let's check on our
meatloaf yes
those juices are bubbling
meatloaf is already looking darker this
glaze is gonna help even more I'm just
gonna glaze it lightly okay you're not
gonna go berserker rage
we're not making a river of roast meat
love dreams here but just giving it a
little shine you can already tell this
baby is so much more moist okay we're
gonna put it back in the oven for about
four minutes and let that glaze get nice
and dark all right this meat looks
smells done you know how I know cuz this
whole kitchen smells like meatloaf
yes ah that's a meatloaf oh so pretty
look at you you're beautiful dog yes
this is so juicy good we're keeping you
and garnish with your parsley Dada
meatloaf ruff jeans let's see what
Gordon thinks this is a work of art but
I love it Thank You Gordon hey if you've
enjoyed this video we got plenty more
don't forget if you've got a dish you
want the Dean just sent a picture or a
video with the hashtag Ramsay redemption
Gordon's gonna talk to trash
best to fix it everything you need to
know in the description box below see
you next time okay my microphone don't
do it oh it's okay I see what's
happening I fell out of my butt
that came out unlike how I intended it
you know what I mean okay okay